ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนมีตา
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสายก็
กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนหรอในวีดีโอระดับดี
กินน่อนะคะถูกต้องนะคะมีหน้าฟ้าก็ต้องฆ่า
ครูฟ้าขาอะไรคะวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้
วันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธแล้ววันพุธที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันพุธที่ 22 ค่ะ
ดีเดือน
เดือน
มกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะศ.
ปี
2556  5 บาทปีคศอะไรคะ
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
วันอังคารที่ 11 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพฤหัสที่ 23 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะวันนี้ก็วันพุธแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วนะคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 10:00 น
10:00 นกี่นาทีคะ
10:22 นาทีค่ะเสร็จโมง 22 นาทีเนาะเป็น
ตอนเช้าก็ยังตอนเช้าใช่ไหม
ที่อเมริกากี่โมงคะผู้หญิงที่อเมริกา
เนี่ย
10:00 น
22 นาทีค่ะแต่ 4 ทุ่ม 22 นาที
อเมริกาเป็นกลางคืนสวยของครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็น
กลางวัน 10 โมงนะนิด
22:22 น
ซะแล้วครูฝาเนี่ย
คิดคิดๆไหนว่าไหมวันนี้
ผู้ใช่ไหมวีดีโอเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าจะไปชอบ
ปิ้ง
ไปซื้อของไปเดินเล่น
คิด
กูบาร์คิดว่าถ้าครูป๊าอัดวีดีโอเสร็จใช่
ไหมหาเสร็จแล้วก็พาก็จะไปดูหนัง
กูไปจะไปดูหนัง
ไปเดอร์แมนหรอคะจะ
รู้ได้ยังไงคะผู้หญิงไปด้วยใหญ่ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ไปดูหนังก็ต้องไปที่โรงหนังเพลง
เปิดให้ดูนะคะโอเค
นิใช่ไหมอันนี้โรงหนังแล้วก็มี
สไปเดอร์แมนครูฟ้าจะไปดูหนังมีพระจันทร์
ออกจากบ้านไปดูหนังกูฟ้าคิดไหมว่าครูฟ้า
จะแต่งตัวยังไงใส่เสื้ออะไรกางเกงอะไรคิด
ไหม
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
รูปพาสจะวัดตอนนี้สมัยตอนนี้ที่เราอัด
วีดีโอครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่เสื้อสีส้มในเสื้อ
เสื้อที่กูฟ้าใสอะโวคาโดใช่มั้ย
ใช่ฮะโอคาโด้เจอถ้าเราก็ฟ้าคิดว่าครูพระ
จะใส่กางเกงยีนส์
ไหนคะกางเกงยีนส์เลือกอยู่เยอะมาก
รูฝามีกางเกงยีนส์ขายาวหรือว่าขาสั้นนะคะ
มีค่ะสั้นก็มีค่ะขาสั้นกางเกงยีนขาสั้น
กางเกงยีนขาสั้นขาสั้นแล้วก็กางเกงยีนส์
พี่ขายาว
กางเกงยีนส์ขายาวยาวว่ายาวมากคุยอีกไหม
ใส่ไม่ได้
ยาวว่าเออ
ไฟฟ้าบีเยอะใช่ไหมกางเกงยีนส์ขาสั้นเอง
ยีนส์ขายาวมีมากๆให้หาแปะกางเกงยีนส์ขา
สั้นมีแค่ 2 ตัวโทรหาอีกตัวนึงตั๊ด 2 ตัว
ส่วนกางเกงยีนส์ขายาวเยอะมากพอ
หลายตัวเลยนะคะก็ยังมีอะไรตู้
อยู่ในตู้หนูฟ้าคิดคิดว่าไปดู
สไปเดอร์แมนเนี่ยจะใส่กางเกงยีนส์ขาสั้น
หรือว่าขายาว
กูฟ้าคิดว่าจะใส่กางเกงยีนส์ขายาวค่ะอ๋อ
ขายาวหายยาวเลยจริง
ก็คิดว่าตอนแรกเนี่ยจะใส่แบบนี้
กางเกงยีนส์ขายาวแต่ว่า
มีแบบอะขานอาหารอะเลยขาดหน้ากางเกงขาดแต่
เวลาไปดูหนังว่า
มันจะในโรงหนังเนี่ยมันมีแอร์เหนือเมฆ
[เพลง]
รอ Part ชอบใส่เสื้อยืด
เสื้อยืดกางเกง in นะค่ะเสร็จเข้าใส่
เสื้อยืดเป็นเสื้อยืดโอเวอร์ไซต์เนาะภาษา
ไทยก็พูดซึ่งยืดโอเวอร์ไซต์นั่นแหละขา
เค้ายืดมาก
ใส่รองเท้าไหมคะ
ป้ายรองเท้า
อันนี้เนาะชิ้นต้องเรื่องรองเท้าสีขาวมา
ด้วยคะนักเรียนจะมองไม่เห็นเอานะคะนี้ใช่
ไหมรองเท้านี้เป็นรองเท้าผ้าใบมาก็ใส่รอง
เท้าผ้าใบๆอย่างอุบะชอบใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบนะ
คะนี่เกอร์หรอนะคะรองเท้าปาก
แล้วเออรองเท้าส้นสูง
รองเท้าแบบนี้รองเท้าเนี่ยส้นสูง
สีฟ้าใส่ไหมคะไปดูสไปเดอร์แมนใช้ลูกค้า
สุดไม่ห่าไม่ใส่ส้นสูงอ่ะไม่ใช่สไตล์อ่ะ
จริงๆสูงเก่งนะ
คะจะมาฟ้าก็จะใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบสมัยรองเท้า
ผ้าใบใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบเนี่ย
ใส่ถุงเท้าไหมคะนี่ยังไม่ได้ใช้นะคะไม่
เป็นไรใส่ถุงเท้าไหม
ใส่ถุงเท้าค่ะใส่ถุงค่ะไปมาจากออกชอบใส่
ถึงเท้านะสีเหลือง
การเภสัชก็ครูฟ้านะอยู่ประเทศไทยสมัย
ประเทศไทยร้อนใส่กางเกงยีนส์ใส่เสื้อยืด
ใช้ใส่เสื้อยืดก็ไปดูสไปเดอร์แมน OK ฮะ
โอเคไม่มีอะไรอ่ะเออแต่
ผู้หญิงๆแตกผู้หญิงเนี่ยนิวยอร์กเนี่ย
หนาวมากๆท่านผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อยืดแล้วก็
เดินเดินเดินแล้วเข้าไปดูสไปเดอร์แมน
เนี่ยเพื่อ
ไม่ได้ไม่เหมือนครูฟ้าประเทศไทยสบายๆ
รู้แล้วผู้หญิงต้องแต่งตัวยังไงอ่ะอยู่
อเมริกาเนี่ยแต่งตัวไม่เหมือนที่ไทยหรอ
ตายฆ่าข้างล่างใช่มั้ยก็เหมือนกันก็คือ
ใส่กางเกงยีนส์โอเคใส่กางเกงยีนส์เนี่ยขา
ยาวนะคะขายาวแต่ว่าคุณต้องครับเนาะทับขา
ว่าเป็นตัวเล็กๆนะคะมีนิสัยนะคะก็ใส่
กางเกงยีนส์อันนี้เหมือนครูฟ้ารายการใช่
มั้ยเหมือนประเทศไทยออกอากาศหนาวเนี่ยใส่
กางเกงยีนส์โอเคเนอะโอเคบายแบบเลือกเนี่ย
ไม่เหมือนไหมอ่ะใส่เสื้อยืดไม่ได้เหรอหาก
ผู้หญิงที่ใส่เสื้อยืดใช่ไหมคะเสื้อยืด
เสื้อยืด 1 ตัวเดินข้างนอกป่ะไม่ได้ก็ใส่
เสื้อยืด 1 นะเสื้อยืด
อาจจะใส่เป็นฮู้ดดี้ใช้เสื้อฮู้ดดี้มี
ฮู๊ด
2 เสื้อยืดเสื้อฮูดดี้
เสื้อกันหนาว
อันนี้เราเรียกเสื้อกันหนาวเนาะมองเห็น
ไหมดูหญิงเป็นเสื้อกันหนาวใช่ไหมคะอ่ะ
ก็จะนิ่มๆสีดอกใส่อย่างเงี้ยถ้าใส่แขน
อยู่ไหนคะจะไปใส่หน้ามันก็จะแบบ
สบายจะไม่เราเรียกเสื้อกันหนาวผู้หญิง
3 ใส่เสื้อยืด
เสื้อยืด
หูที่
[เพลง]
พบกันเหมือนเสื้อกันหนาวดูไม่ให้รู้
เรื่องเลยเสื้อกันหนาวใช่ไหมเวลาหนาว
ไม่ต้องใส่นะคะ
ร้อนค่ะประเทศไทยใส่เสื้อกันหนาวไม่ได้นะ
คะอันนี้น้องค่ะถ้าประเทศนักเรียนอเมริกา
ก็แบบนี้เนาะเสื้อกันหนาวเสื้อโค้ stir
สมัยเสื้อกันหนาว
แล้วก็มันเสื้อไหมพรมยังไม่หมดนะกูฟ้า
น้องมีอะไรอีกผู้หญิงก็ต้องใส่
ผ้าพันคอ
หนูมี sle ได้
นี่ผ้าพันคอและมีผ้าแล้วก็พันธุ์กบไหนใส่
ผ้าพันคอด้วย
งูงูเป็นราวอันหนาวมากนะนี่หมดนะคะครูฟ้า
มีอะไรอีกค่ะและนอกจากใส่เสื้อยืดใช่ไหม
ใส่เสื้อไหมพรมใส่เสื้อกันหนาวอ่า
ฮันเนาะคันผ้าพันคอสมัยพันผ้าพันคอก็ต้อง
ใส่ม้วน
ใส่หมวกด้วยมันหนาว
รอใส่หมวก
ก็นี่เหมือนคนให้คิมม่วง
ปิดหูสมัยหูเนี่ยหนูเนี่ยมันหาวมาก็ต้อง
ใส่หมวกเนี่ยปิดหูสมัยปิดหูแล้วก็ใส่หมวก
เราไม่หมดล่ะคู่ฟ้ายังมีอีกหรอ
ใส่หูมือ
โห
มันหนาวใช่ไหมตัวต้องใส่ถุงมือไว้ถุงมือ
สองข้าง
ท่านผู้หญิงแต่งตัวออกจากบ้านถ้าผู้หญิง
คิดๆไปดูสไปเดอร์แมนทำไมต้องมีผ้าพันคอ
กอดผ้าพันคอก่อนนะคะว่าตอนนี้อยู่ในบ้าน
5 ร้อนใส่หมวกสมัยมีหมวดอันนี้ก็เป็น
หมวกไหมพรมเนาะหมวกบีนี่นะคะมีถุงมือสวย
มีถุงมือคืนหนาวมากเสื้อไหมพรมคือแล้ว
มีอะไรอีกหาซื้อกันหนาวเสื้อกันหนาวสมัย
ที่เป็นเสื้อกันเขาแล้วผู้หญิงใส่ถุงเท้า
ไหมคะ
ก็ต้องใส่ถุงเท้าแล้วหวยครูป๊าดาราใส่ถุง
เท้าแล้วก็ใส่ถุงมือไว้ใส่ถุงมือ
นิสัยที่มือใส่กินมือใส่ถุงมือใส่ถุงถ้า
ทาวน์เฮ้าส์แล้วก็ใส่รองเท้า
รองเท้าอะไรอ่ะใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบได้ป่าว
หรือว่าใส่รองเท้าบูท
รองเท้าปู๊ด
วิ่งมีรองเท้าบูท
ไม่ใช่รองเท้าบูทแบบนี้สิคะ
อ่าแบบนี้แบบนี้ใช่ไหมรองเท้าบูทรองเท้า
บูท
[เพลง]
มันจะได้แบบไม่หนาว
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อนใช่
ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ต้องมีไม่ต้องใส่ผ้าพัน
คอไม่ต้องพันผ้าพันคอต้องหาไม่ต้องใส่ถุง
มือ
ต้องหมวก
อ่ะ
ไข่แฟชั่นแต่ไม่ใช่หมวกบีนี่
ภูฟ้าต้องใส่หมวกอันนี้ได้เนาะหมวกแก๊ป
ชายจ๊ะ
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมกูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่หมวกแก๊ปหมด Rap
แบบนี้ได้ไหมที่ประเทศไทยโอเคๆหมู market
อะหมกอะไรเป็นยังไงคะหมวกปาเก็ตหมวก
บักเก็ตมหาเปิดให้ดูว่าชอบมากหมวก
ปากเกร็ด
ก็ไม่ได้อยู่มามันจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะเวลาใส่
สิ
อาหารหมวกปากเกร็ด
มี
สาย 7 นะ
แต่ว่าถ้าครูฟ้าครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงน่ะเป็น
ผู้หญิงสมัยบางครั้งแหละผู้ขอไลน์ผู้ชาย
เนี่ย
ก็บางคนก็อาจจะใส่เสื้อแบบนี้ก็ได้เนอะ
เสื้อเชิ้ตใช่ไหมเสื้อเชิ้ตผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ไม่มีนะคะไม่ค่อยมีความเหมือนเสื้อครูฟ้า
ไหมเนี่ยกูฟ้าก็เป็นเสื้อเชิ้ตเดี๋ยวผมขอ
โทษเด้อจะดูไม่เชื่อต่อว่าเป็นเชิ้ตแขน
สั้น
อันนี้อันนี้เชิ้ตแขนสั้นหรือแขนยาวคะอัน
นี้ดันเชิ้ตแขนยาว
อันนี้เฉยแคปตั้น
หรือว่าผู้หญิงใช่ไหมเราเป็นผู้หญิงไม่
ใส่กางเกงกางเกงยีนส์เขาจะมี
ยายอ่ะอาจจะใส่กระโปรง
ใช่ไหมกูนี่กระโปรงราคาใส่กระโปรงแต่ว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ใส่กระโปรงไม่ค่อยใส่ขี้
โกงหากผู้หญิงหนาว
หนาวเท่าไม่ใส่กระโปร่งให้เลคกิ้งอ่ะ
อะไรต้องมีเลกกิ้งใช่ไหมค่ะบางคนก็มี
เลกกิ้ง
ตายค่ะหรือว่าผู้หญิงบางคนเนี่ยก็อาจจะ
ใส่เป็นชุดเดรสเนอะแบบนี้ใช่ไหมสุด Trace
นะคะชุดกระโปรงและเป็นเดรส Miss ผู้หญิง
ก็เป็นแต่งตัวออกจากบ้านซึ่งถ้านักเรียน
อยู่ประเทศไทยก็สบายๆทำไมใส่เสื้อยืด
เนาะใส่เสื้อยืดกางเกงยีนส์ก็เสร็จแล้วไป
ดูหนังไปดูสไปเดอร์แมนโอเคแต่ถ้านักเรียน
อยู่ก็เท่นะเหงาเหมือนครูหญิงก็ต้องเป็น
ยังไงวะกี่โมงมี
ถุงมือสวยมีคู่มือมีถ้าพันคอมีเสื้อโค้ท
มีแจ็คเก็ตนะมีเสื้อกันหนาวสำหรับให้แบบ
คือไม่หนาวไปเวลาจะแต่งตัวแล้วก็ออกจาก
บ้าน
เยอะเลยนะการแต่งตัวเนาะเอ่อสวัสดี
เกี่ยวกับการแต่งตัวนักเรียนแต่งตัวแบบ
ไหนก็คอมเม้นได้นะคะนักเรียนไปเรียนใส่
หมวกไหมนะนักเรียนออกจนบ้านมาใส่หมวกไหม
ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้หรอวันนี้เราสองคนก็
ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าบ๊าย
บายสวัสดีค่ะเมื่อ
[เพลง]